RUSSIA IS LAUNCHING ANOTHER
BARRAGE OF MISSILE ATTACKS
TODAY, AT LEAST FOUR PEOPLE WERE
KILLED AND SEVERAL OTHERS WERE
HURT AS RUSSIAN FORCES CONTINUE
TO TARGET CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AT THE VERY SAME TIME, PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS NOW DISPUTING PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY'S TAKE ON THE DEADLY
EXPLOSION THIS POLAND THIS WEEK.
NIC ROBERTSON IS LIVE IN KYIV AT
THIS HOUR WITH THE LATEST.
SO THE BOMBARDMENT WITH RUSSIA
CONTINUES.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING ABOUT THE
LATEST WAVE OF MISSILE ATTACKS?
>> Reporter: WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT VITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FACILITIES HIT
AND IN DNIPRO AND THE
ZAPORIZHZHIA, WHERE THE FOUR
PEOPLE WERE KILLED, 14 INJURED
IN DNIPRO.
IN ODESA IN THE SOUTH, VITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AGAIN TARGETED
THERE.
KHARKIV AS WELL IN THE
NORTHEAST.
HERE IS KYIV, THE MISSILE
INTERCEPTIONS WERE EFFECTIVE
FOUR KRUSE MISSILES WERE TAKEN
OUT AND FIVE DRONES, BUT WHAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM THE ENERGY
SECTOR HERE IS THAT AT ABOUT 40%
OF THE COUNTRY IS WITHOUT
ELECT
ELECTRICITY THE MOMENT AND
SIGNIFICANTLY TODAY WE HAVE
HEARD FROM THE GAS SECTOR HERE
WHO SAY THAT THIS IS THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS NOW BEING
TARGETED AS WELL.
SO RUSSIA HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
DEGRADED THE ELECTRICAL POWER
GENERATING AND DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM AS WELL AS KILLING
CIVILIANS ALONG THE WAY.
AND IS NOW TARGETING THE HEATING
SYSTEM, THE TEMPERATURES HAVE
DROPPED HERE.
YOU SEE SNOW BEHIND ME AND IT IS
FREEZING.
THE POWER ENGINEERS HERE SAY
THAT BECAUSE IT IS SO COLD
PEOPLE ARE TURNING ON THEIR
METERS AN THAT IS GOING TO
CREATE MORE INSTABILITY IN THE
SYSTEM.
RUSSIA INTENTIONALLY TRYING TO
BRING DOWN UKRAINE'S RESOLVE TO
FIGHT THE WAR.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY'S STATEMENT,
HE HAS SIGNIFICANTLY MOVED HIS
POSITION, HIS LATEST IS TO SAY
VERY, VERY CLEARLY, FALLING IN
LINE WITH WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
UNDERSTANDS, WHAT WITH NATO
LEADERS ARE SAYING, I SAID I
DON'T KNOW FOR SURE WHAT
HAPPENED AND THE WORLD DOESN'T
KNOW FOR SURE.
I AM SURE, SAID, IT WAS A
RUSSIAN MISSILE AND I'M SURE
THAT WE FIRED OUR AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEM.
AND THERE WAS A RUSSIAN MISSILE
THAT FIRED AT AND IS FALLING IN
LINE WITH WHAT EVERYONE ELSE IS
SAYING.
>> NICK, THANK YOU.
>>> AND CNN IS LEARNING NEW ZEE
ILL THATS ABOUT THE BEHIND THE
SCENES SCRAMBLE TO GET TO THE
FACTS OF WHAT HAPPENED IN THAT
DEADLY STRIKE IN POLAND THAT
KILLED TWO PEOPLE.
THE AIM OF THE INVESTIGATION NOW
IS OF COURSE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
AND ALSO TO PREVENT FURTHER
ESCALATION BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
NATO ALLIES.
NATASHA BERTRAND IS LIVE WITH
ALL OF THE DETAILS.
WHAT RARE YOU HEARING.
>> >> Reporter: PRESIDENT BIDEN
IN BALI WAS WOKE UNIN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT THAT A STRIKE HAD
HIT POLAND AND THAT IT HAD
KILLED TWO PEOPLE.
NOW THIS LED TO A SERIES OF VERY
URGENT CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
BIDEN AND HIS POLISH COUNTER
PART PRESIDENT DUDA AND AS WELL
AS THE NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER
JAKE SULLIVAN AND HIS POLISH
COUNTERPART.
A NUMBER OF CALLS BACK AND FORTH
TO TRY TO ESTABLISH WHAT HAD
HAPPENED AND WHERE THE MISSILE
HAD COME FROM AND MAKE SURE THAT
THIS WAS NOT ACTUALLY A
DELIBERATE ATTACK BY RUSSIA ON
POLISH TERRITORY.
OF COURSE, POLAND IS A NATO
ALLY.
SO THAT IS THE HEART OF THE
DISCUSSIONS.
AN IT BECAME EARLY ON THAT THIS
WAS NOT A DELIBERATE ATTACK AND
IT WAS LIKELY ACCIDENTAL AND
LIKELY A MISSILE THAT UKRAINE
HAD FIRED THAT THEN LANDED
ACCIDENTALLY IN POLAND.
AND SO AS THIS WAS ALL BECOMING
CLEAR BASED ON INTELLIGENCE THE
U.S. WAS RECEIVING AND BASED ON
THE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE POLS,
THE KRUKRAINIANS BELIEVED THIS S
A RUSSIAN MISSILE.
THAT WAS NOT VERY HELPFUL.
JAKE SULLIVAN DID CALL HIS
UKRAINIAN COUNTERPARTS AND SAY
TO THEM, LOOK, LET'S WAIT OFF
AND HOLD AND SEE WHAT THE
INVESTIGATION ACTUALLY UNCOVERS.
SO NOW IT IS JUST A WAIT AND SEE
GAME, AND WHAT THE UKRAINIAN
INVESTIGATORS UNCOVER AND THEY
ARE AT THE SITE IN THE POLAND
LOOKING AT THIS FOR THEMSELVES,
KATE.
>> WE'LL SEE.
THANK YOU.
>>> JOINING ME NOW FOR MORE IS
ADAM SMITH, THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
I SAW YOU SAY YESTERDAY THAT IN
THE END IT DOESN'T ULTIMATELY
MATTER WHOSE MISSILE IT WAS
BECAUSE IT IS ALL CAUSED BY
RUSSIA.
YOU HAVE DUDA ALREADY LOWERING
THE TEMPERATURE TRYING TO, BY
CALLING IT A TRAGIC ACCIDENT,
WHY THEN DO YOU THINK ZELENSKYY
IS NOW SO INSISTENT THAT IT IS
NOT THEM.
IF IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME
WHEN NO ONE IS TRYING TO BLAME
THEM?
>> WELL, I THINK THE ONLY THING
TO KEEP IN MIND IS THAT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HAS A LOT ON
HIS PLATE.
DEALING WITH THE INVASION AND
THE MISSILES COMING IN AND
TRYING TO KEEP THE MILITARY ON
HIS SIDE.
HE SHOULD NOT BE SAYING THAT.
BUT THINK IT IS PRETTY
UNDERSTANDABLE WHY HE MIGHT NOT
GET THE SPECIFICS OF THIS RIGHT.
I THINK THE BIG POINT IS
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS TEAM
REALLY STEPPED UP AND HANDLED
THIS SITUATION WITH EXACTLY THE
PROFESSIONALISM THAT IT NEEDED.
AND IT REMINDS US AGAIN HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO HAVE A
PRESIDENT WITH THE LEVEL OF
EXPERIENCE THAT JOE BIDEN HAS.
TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE THE
SITUATION, TO CALM IT DOWN, TO
PREVENT ANY ESCALATION AND WORK
WITH THE UKRAINIANS AND THE
POLS.
AND ALSO THE POINT, RUSSIA
INVADED.
RUSSIA IS LAUNCHING MISSILES ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
THE REASON IT LANDED IN POLAND
IS BECAUSE OF RUSSIA AND WE DO
NEED TO BE CLEAR ON THAT POINT.
>> YEAH.
CHAIRMAN, THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF HAS BEEN
LAYING OUT HIS POSITION, HIS
TAKE AND POSITION OF THE STATE
OF THE WAR.
HE SAID LAST WEEK WHEN THERE IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO NEGOTIATE,
WHEN PEACE CAN BE ACHIEVED,
SEIZE IT.
AND I WANT TO PLAY WHAT HE SAID
YESTERDAY.
PLEASE LISTEN.
>> THE RUSSIAN MILITARY IS
HURTING BAD.
SO YOU WANT TO NEGOTIATE AT A
TIME WHEN YOU'RE AT YOUR
STRENGTH AND YOU'RE OPPONENT IS
AT WEAKNESS.
AND IT IS POSSIBLE, MAYBE, THAT
THAT THEY'LL BE A POLITICAL
SOLUTION.
>> THAT REALLY DOES NOT APPEAR
TO BE IN LOCKSTEP WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S POSITION THAT UKRAINE
GETS TO DECIDE WHEN THEY AND IF
THEY WANT TO NEGOTIATE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THESE
DIFFERENT POSITIONS?
>> WELL, I'VE SPOKEN WITH
CHAIRMAN MILLEY YESTERDAY ABOUT
WHAT IS GOING ON IN UKRAINE.
I DON'T THINK IT IS THAT BIG OF
A DIFFERENCE.
I THINK WE HAVE BEEN CLEAR,
BIDEN, PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS BEEN
CLEAR THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING
UKRAINE.
WE'RE GETTING THEM ALL OF THE
WEAPONS THEY NEED TO TAKE BACK
AS MUCH TERRITORY AS THEY
POSSIBLY CAN.
BUT THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF BACK
CHANNEL CONVERSATIONS GOING ON.
JAME SULLIVAN WAS THERE KYIV A
WEEK AGO HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS, ABOUT TWO STEPS
HERE.
WELL THREE, ACTUALLY.
ONE, WE WANT THE UKRAINES TO BE
AS SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE IN THE
BATTLEFIELD AND WE'VE HELPED
THEM IN BEING VERY SUCCESS.
AND TWO, WE DON'T WANT TO GO TO
WAR WITH RUSSIA OR NATO TO GO TO
WAR WITH RUSSIA.
WE'RE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT THAT
AGAIN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S LEADERSHIP HAS
ENABLED HIM TO ACCOMPLISH BOTH
OF THOSE THINGS.
NUMBER THREE, WE WANT PEACE.
WE WANT THE WAR TO STOP.
WE HAVE GOT TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT WE ARE INTERESTED IN
GETTING TO THAT END POINT.
AND THAT, I THINK, IS IN KEEPING
WITH WHAT CHAIRMAN MILLEY SAID.
HE DOESN'T SAY TO FORCE THE
UKRAINIANS TO GIVE UP TERRITORY,
HE SAID WE HAVE TO LOOK HOW WE
GET TO THE END OF THIS.
AND I THINK THAT IS A VERY
CONSISTENT MESSAGE HITTING ON
THE THREE POINTS ALL CHF ARE
CRUCIAL TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND TO
HELP UKRAINE TO THE BEST OF OUR
ABILITY.